LIKE BRUCE SPRINGSTEEN.
NOW THE BOSS IS HITTING BACK
WITH THIS DIG AT TRUMP.
>> WE'RE LIVING IN A FRIGHTENING
TIME.
THE STEWARDSHIP OF THE NATION IS
BEING THROWN AWAY.
HE DOESN'T HAVE A CLUE OF WHAT
IT MEANS.
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE SOMEBODY
THAT DOESN'T HAVE A GRASP OF THE
DEEP MEANING OF WHAT IT MEANS TO
BE AN AMERICAN.
>> GREG, YOU WERE IN THE
CELEBRITY WORLD.
>> Greg: I AM A CELEBRITY.
>> DO THEY BELIEVE --
>> Greg: LAWRENCE, I'M A WORLD
CLASS CELEBRITY AND I'M INSULTED
CLASS CELEBRITY AND I'M INSULT D
INSULTED --
>> DO THEY BELIEVE THEY HAVE
THIS MUCH POWER?
>> Greg: IT'S HAD FOR BRUCE
SPRINGSTEEN BECAUSE HE'S A BLUE
COLLAR PERSONA.
TRUMP IS A FOLK HERO.
THERE'S A LOT OF OVERLAP WITH
SPRINGSTEEN'S AUDIENCE AND PRO
TRUMPERS AND DRIVING HIM CRAZY.
THEIR TRUMP POPULARITY IS
BEING -- YOU WONDERING WHY
DOESN'T THIS COUNTER THE RISE OF
THIS NOXIOUS ENEMY?
WHAT AM I CHOPPED LIVER?
>> Dana: NO.
IN THE CULTURAL DELL KA
IN THE CULTURAL DELL K
IN THE CULTURAL DELL CO
IN THE CULTURAL DELL COUT
IN THE CULTURAL DELL COUTUR
IN THE CULTURAL DELL COUTURE
IN THE CULTURAL DELL COUTURE -
IN THE CULTURAL DELL COUTURE --
DELI, YOU'RE NOT.
>> Geraldo: BRUCE SPRINGSTEEN
WAS ANY NEIGHBOR.
WE WERE THERE FOR 9-11.
OUR COMMUNITY WAS THE MOST
STRIKEN IN THE WORLD.
WHAT HE DID TO HELP THAT
COMMUNITY WAS REALLY AMAZING.
HE'S RIGHT ABOUT -- I THINK THE
RIGHT GENERALLY REPUBLICANS AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP LOSING SIGHT OF
SOMETHING VERY CRUCIALLY
AMERICAN.
I THINK WHEN THE PRESIDENT SAID
HE WAS GOING TO BAN ALL MUSLIM
IMMIGRANTS WHEN HE SEPARATED
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES AT THE
BORDER, THOSE THINGS ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY AND I AGREE WITH
BRUISE SPRINGSTEEN, THEY'RE
UN-AMERICAN.
THAT'S WHAT BRUCE --
>> Greg: AND ADULTS --
>> Geraldo: WHAT?
>> Greg: IF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH CHILDREN TRAVELING WITH
PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT RELATED TO,
YOU HAVE TO DO SOME SEPARATION.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE THE PROCESS.
I DON'T MAKE IT.
OBAMA DID THE SAME THING.
>> Geraldo: THESE ARE TWO BLACK
MARKS ON THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY
THAT HISTORY WILL COME TO REGARD
AND BRUCE IS RIGHT TO POINT THEM
OUT.
>> LET'S GET YOU -- A LOT OF
PEOPLE DON'T CARE ABOUT HIS
PERSONALITY.
THEY CARE WHAT HE DELIVERS ON.
>> Kennedy: THAT'S TRUE.
AND YOU KNOW THE PRESIDENT VERY
WELL.
I WOULD SAY --
>> Geraldo: I LOVE HIM, TOO.
HE'S NOT PERFECT.
>> Kennedy: HE'S NOT PERFECT.
I --
>> Greg: THAT'S WHERE YOU'RE
DIFFERENT FROM JESSE.
HE WOULD HAVE SAID PERFECT.
>> Kennedy: RIGHT NOW HE'S CRAFT
AGO SCULPTURE OF THE PRESIDENT.
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
IT'S LIKE LIONEL RICHIE'S HELLO.
>> Geraldo: MANY LEMON SORBET.
>> Kennedy: THE PRESIDENT SAYS A
LOT OF THINGS I DON'T AGREE WITH
AND I DON'T LIKE THAT ARE I
THINK ARE BENEATH THE
PRESIDENCY.
I WOULDN'T SAY HE DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND AMERICA OR HE'S NOT
AN AMERICAN.
HE DOES EMBODY THE AMERICAN
DREAM.
YOU KNOW, HERE'S SOMEONE THAT
DID WHAT HE LOVED FOR A LONG
TIME, DID VERY WELL AT IT AND
NOW HE'S PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AGAINST ALL ODDS.
WHEN HE GOES OUT TO THESE
RALLIES, ONE OF THE REASONS
THEY'RE SO WELL-ATTENDED, HE
TALKS DIRECTLY TO PEOPLE ABOUT
HIS DREAM AND ABOUT HIS
ASPIRATIONS.
THAT RESONATES.
FOR PEOPLE THAT DEMONIZE THEM
LIKE BRUCE SPRINGSTEEN THAT ARE
SO READY TO CALL HIM A MORON,
YOU SHOULD OPERATE WITH MORE
CURIOSITY --
>> Geraldo: SHOULDN'T GO FOR THE
SHORT MONEY.
>> KENNEDY IS RIGHT.
THEY'RE AVERAGE DAY PEOPLE.
>> Dana: ENTERTAINERS COULD MAKE
A CHOICE.
IN NASHVILLE, IN COUNTRY MUSIC,
YOU CAN IMAGINE, THEY HAVE A
WIDE AUDIENCE.
A LOT OF DIVERSE AUDIENCE.
THEY WANT TO KEEP IT.
THEY NEVER TALK ABOUT POLITICS.
THEY'RE THERE TO LIFT AND
ENTERTAIN.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
>> DON'T GO ANYWHERE.
THE FASTEST SELF IS COMING UP ON
"THE FIVE."
♪♪